Aria allows us to express an extremely
broad range of semantic concepts
via the use of HTML attributes.
Obviously Aria is a very complex topic
and it can take a long time to learn
all of the precise details of the best
use of Aria roles, states, and
properties, and special roles and
attributes like Aria Live.
The Aria Practices document is
a great place to get information for
well-known Aria best practices and
design patterns.
And the Aria spec has all
of the nitty gritty details
of what each of the roles and attributes
does if you need to take a deeper dive.
Then like any skill, it's a matter
of experimentation, practice and
persistence.
There is no substitute for trying things
out with the real world assistive
technology, especially screen readers.
And keep an eye out because browsers are
also developing tooling which will start
to make all of this easier.
However it bears repeating that
if you don't need to use Aria,
you can just not.
Implicit HTML semantics can
get you a very long way and
will save you a lot of effort in
re-implementing the semantics and
behaviors of many standard
user experience patterns.
So that wraps up our
discussion of semantics.
It's been a long journey, but we're
not quite done with the course yet.
While we definitely need to make
sure are semantics are in order for
assistive technology users, we also
need to make sure that the visual UI
is usable for everyone as well.
So in the next lesson,
Rob is going to explain the role that
styling can play in accessibility.